sorry for my panic is helping this is
helping hello can you see me this is
Morse code for don't think that's my
life motto anyway I don't think on a
daily basis so you don't need to worry
about that if there's something that I
don't do its thing
oh I am sorry for everything I've ever
done I don't know you should do I'm busy
doing official Park Ranger stuff what is
that hello hi who's there
hi who is that peek your head through
hey shorty jump I got the code oh sorry
this is so stupid
the tiny little submarine aboard a tiny
nuclear McCloud okay oh my god oh [ __ ]
missed my jump well I'm gonna sprint you
far away from Lady ice lady ice ain't
gonna get me lady ice could go suck a
[ __ ] cover your shame cover your shame
hey hey I wish you was naked under here
not that I wish he was naked under here
don't get me don't get me wrong one is
bad look a sack that's fun oh no it's a
ball sorry I always get my sacks
confused with my balls
maybe nuts oh hi what the [ __ ] hi hello
holy [ __ ] you scared the piss out of me
hi ding ding Oh Dutch see pop the judge
sees the Dutch season I go in this
building please tell me okay well if I
could just stop power jumping okay if I
could get it off okay I'll take the ramp
I oh hi hello oh never mind
you know what bail bail bailing on that
Oh bail Oh Christian Bale no damn you Oh
hey easy there big scary screaming
contest huh
oh oh hi oh hi hello everybody my name
is markiplier oh you know what the
monster pulling nose away from me don't
uncover my invisible body bouquet hello
great
my ears are dead everything from my own
your dog horrible oh my god Oh should I
do something about that I got a crank my
flashlight around and yank on my sheets
outside no to it asleep interpret it is
time to view notebook just in case I
forget I'd like to write myself little
tidbits of reminders imagining that I'm
in a video game okay I know that that's
Morse code over in the access code and I
gotta
hello my name is Mark bar okay goodbye
horrible Oh got your nose I guess what
why why whoa why why what [ __ ] you're
just gonna say [ __ ] about that just like
that's a [ __ ] of a moment that's just
like no [ __ ] I got my ass eaten out
wait no hang on that was t IIT which
stands for Ted Oh
oh my god what a [ __ ] going on here
wait this is the ending of the demo
before whoo hi oh hey oh whoa hi
okay whoa yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah need a flower okay so I gotta get a
flat work I think someone shout out a
flower in the bathroom back there let me
this is not the please subscribe
subscribe that like button where would
if I was a code Oh
[Music]
those are some funky parallel I'm coming
hey knock knock
here's Freddie oh hey how's it go hey
listen I don't know bee-garden
thought oh my webcam froze well that's
weird why did that happen and why did it
freeze on that face Oh am i back ok I'm
back now
I don't know why froze or when but now
it froze again why what the [ __ ] oh no
oh [ __ ] he made it down he was a dreamer
he was a dreamer and he made it down
finally I always knew he could do it I
always believed in him
zoom in on those eyes there's something
going on in those eyes my face is frozen
God [ __ ] a duck are we back we're gonna
stay back okay I'm watching me zoom in
on that face something's going on here
my camera froze what why whatever
oh hey reg why the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
forget again again with this [ __ ] there
I am cuz I of course is gonna [ __ ]
happen when my damn plane one of the
coolest horror games I've played in a
long time and he's gonna [ __ ] with me
froze god oh it pulsates who wants to
become part of me sure I regret
everything I've ever done in my life is
dark to me I nice tuchus water [ __ ]
up oh my god oh oh all the time always
locked them door I don't feel like
relaxing I'm gonna paint some happy
little demons I don't know why my
eyeballs is a VCR recorder I'm just
gonna let that slide by I'm assuming
that I'm a vlogger back in the 80s all
right test bed number one what is what
by me don't just do that that's the game
I play on you does it behind you Rob
good they've got chains and wire over
the windows for safety so I think we've
left the realm of reality some I think
we're in the realm of alternate reality
Oh green screen am ia youtuber or a club
[Music]
no mom why do you always call now mom
never leave this way never leave through
the front door what's what's the weird
big pulsating vagina rock good my first
blind of defense but what was dad with a
demon Paul feed me Billy Oh
you got it buddy
[Applause]
my god
I think I might have broken it I might
have broken it in the attempt to shoot a
hole whoa whoa wouldn't it notice this
okay that's that's marginally less
horrible that's and cap lunk all right
no one's gonna notice that okay oh this
is uncomfortable yeah no joke yeah no
joke
oh oh oh this one got messed up oh this
one's messed up Zach gasps so yummy good
okay good Oh
[Music]